un elevador típico en un edificio puede
soportar un peso máximo de
aproximadamente una y media toneladas
suponiendo que un adulto promedio pesa
160 libras
cuál es el máximo número de adultos que
puede cargar el elevador sin correr
riesgos
bueno pues debemos pasar esta capacidad
máxima libras y luego ver esas libras
cuántos adultos son déjame empezar con
la capacidad esa capacidad es una y
media toneladas lo voy a poner aquí una
y media toneladas toneladas muy bien
aquí tenemos un número mixto pero para
hacer conversiones es mucho mejor tener
fracciones impropias así que lo primero
que voy a hacer es pasar esto a una
fracción impropia 1 es 2 medios y si a
dos medios le sumamos un medio que da
tres medios entonces esto es lo mismo
que tres entre dos toneladas la forma
rápida de hacerlo es simplemente
multiplicar uno por dos que es 2 y sumar
1 que es 3
entonces nos queda 3 medios
ahora queremos pasar estas toneladas a
libras y por por conocimiento previo
sabemos que hay dos mil libras en cada
tonelada lo voy a poner acá dos mil
libras
libras en cada tonelada en cada tonelada
esto no está aquí escrito en el problema
esto es conocimiento previo que es
conveniente memorizar para resolver este
tipo de problemas bueno para realizar la
conversión de toneladas a libras debemos
multiplicar por algo y ese algo lo que
debe lograr es que las unidades de
toneladas se cancelen y que arriba nos
queden libras entonces vamos a
multiplicar multiplicar por algo que
tenga toneladas en el denominador y que
tenga libras en el numerador libras
y verás muy bien bueno pues cuántas
libras hay en una tonelada es esto que
pusimos aquí verdad hay dos mil dos mil
libras en cada tonelada este uno lo
puedo poner o no en realidad no altera
la expresión bueno pues que nos quedaría
toneladas se cancela con toneladas y la
expresión sería la siguiente sería tres
medios tres medios
x 2000 es más déjame ponerlo así lo voy
a poner ya como fracción 3 x 2 mil 2000
dividido entre 2 entre 2 y eso sería en
libras
bueno esta es la forma en la cual uno lo
hace con mucho cuidado asegurándose de
que queden las unidades correspondientes
y utilizando los factores de conversión
en realidad podríamos hacerlo
mentalmente verdad si hay 2000 libras
por tonelada y tenemos tres y media
toneladas multiplicamos tres medios por
dos mil eso sería para hacerlo
mentalmente pero bueno con esto lo
hacemos con un poco más de cuidado y nos
aseguramos que nos queden las unidades
que queremos ahora sí déjame realizar el
producto 2000 entre 2 es 1000 aquí queda
1000 y 3 por mil es igual a 3000
entonces esto de aquí es igual a 3 mil
3.000 libras libras y tiene sentido que
3000 sea un número mayor a 1 y medio
porque estamos pasando de una unidad
mayor
una unidad menor bueno ahora ya tenemos
el peso máximo el peso máximo una y
media toneladas en libras son 3.000
libras pero ahora queremos saber cuántos
adultos es eso y nos dicen que un adulto
promedio pesa 160 entonces bastaría con
dividir 3000 entre 160 sin embargo vamos
a hacerlo como lo hicimos aquí con un
poco más de cuidado para ver que
realmente las unidades nos queden bien
entonces voy a poner ahora en color
verde estas libras aquí entonces van a
ser 300 libras libras
vibras y ahora queremos multiplicar por
un factor de conversión que nos mande
libras a personas entonces déjame
ponerle aquí que en el denominador
queremos que nos quede libras libras y
en el numerador personas
zonas bueno y que factor tenemos que
poner aquí bueno pues cada persona una
persona pesa 160 libras un adulto
promedio y en efecto sale la operación
que queríamos verdad libra se cancela
con libras y hay que multiplicar tres
mil por uno en 360 pero eso es
exactamente lo mismo que hacer tres mil
entre 160 como pensamos desde el inicio
bueno déjame ponerle que esto es igual a
tres mil tres mil dividido entre 160
entre 160 y la unidad que queda es
personas
son las muy bien vamos a simplificar un
poco este número aquí es 3000 podemos
dividir entre 10 arriba y abajo este 0
se va con este 0 nos queda 300 entre 16
todavía comparten un factor 2 300 entre
2 es 150 16 entre 12 8 y todavía
comparten un factor 2 déjame ponerlo
aquí para para tener más espacio nos
quedaría 150 entre 8 personas
personas
entonces seguimos simplificando 150
entre 12 75 y 8 entre dos es cuatro así
que nos queda 75 entre 4 vamos a hacer
esa división aquí del lado derecho donde
tenemos más espacio vamos a ponerle 75
dividido entre 4 entre 4 creo que aquí
voy a tener que alargar esto un poco más
a ver 4 caben 7 una vez una por 4 es 4
restamos 7 menos 4 estrés baja el 54
cabe 8 veces en 35 4 por 8 es 32 si
restamos 35 menos 32 estrés aquí va un 0
después del punto decimal que baja 4
cada vez 7 veces en 30 pongo aquí el
punto 7 por 4 es 28 restamos 30 menos 28
es 2 aquí hay otro 0 lo voy a poner más
bonito todavía más bonito ese 0 baja 4
cabe 5 veces en 20 exactamente 5 veces 5
por 4 es 20
restamos y aquí nos queda 0 entonces 75
entre 4 o bien 150 entre 8 o 3000 en 360
es lo mismo que 18.75 entonces esta
expresión es igual es igual a 18 puntos
75 75 personas personas vamos a ver si
con esto ya responda respondimos la
pregunta la pregunta es cuál es el
máximo número de adultos que puede
cargar el elevador sin correr riesgos
bueno pues obtuvimos que que la
capacidad de 18.75 personas así que si
puede cargar a 18 adultos pero a 19
novedad o sea si tuviéramos 19 adultos
nos excedemos nos excedemos de la
capacidad y no sé a lo mejor el elevador
se puede caer pero bueno entonces el
máximo sería 18 a 2